for more on this I'm joined Now by Texas
Republican Congressman Randy Weber
Congressman
welcome thank you we expect language on
a bipartisan border deal in the United
States Senate lat later today what do
you
anticipate what we're anticipating Mike
isn't good uh if what we're hearing is
correct and we'll get the language and
we'll look at and as you may know I
served four years in the Texas house my
second term I was the vice chairman of
the borders committee committee back
then it was bad then it's worse now if
we get that language and what we're
hearing is they're going to allow 5,000
illegals a day it's DOA in my view all
right well you're a Texas lawmaker are
you comfortable waiting until next year
when perhaps there's a republican in the
White
House well no we shouldn't have to
Governor Abbott has it exactly correct
we have the right to defend our borders
the federal government has failed
miserably I appreciate Jeff Paul being
down Eagle Pass and the fact that he
said according to the figure of 7 The
Crossings are now 76% down of course
they are Texas and they're going to
other states uh Texas is doing something
to defend ourselves and kudos to Greg
Abbott you know he ought to tell Joe
Biden that Joe Biden has failed
miserably we're going to do what it
takes we don't care what the federal
government says the house is expected to
vote on impeachment of Homeland Security
secretary Alejandro mayorcas this week
what do you
expect well I expect that they'll pass
it out um I'm hoping they will because
obviously he is abreg his his
responsibility to protect Americans when
he goes and testifies to a senate in or
in a Committee hearing and says that
they they have operational control of
the Border how stupid does he think we
are we're having more Americans killed
with fitel than ever in our history more
sex trafficking than ever in our history
it's all because because Biden has hung
out the open for business sign at the
border and mycus the vice president and
the president has done zip zero to do
anything about it and so he's failed
failed at his job keeping American Safe
he's number one job is to keep Americans
safe protect him and he has not lived up
to the oath of his office house Speaker
Mike Johnson today talked about the
house voting this week on an Israel only
only funding bill let's play
it this border is out of control all
these problems have mounted and the
Senate has been dithering ever since we
cannot wait anymore the reason we are
going to send the new Israel package
over is because the time is urgent and
we have to take care of that
responsibility is that right to break
this up into individual pieces and in
this case an Israel only funding
package well absolutely it is my view
Mike because they want to use Israel our
greatest Ally and I'm a great supporter
of Israel rightfully so they're they're
the one stabilizing forces in the Middle
East for example why we should be their
greatest Ally M and they want to link
that to Ukraine or even any other bills
uh whether it's border Ukraine or what
else no let's help our Ally Israel don't
try to hold the house hostage let's get
this done let's get it done now I'm
Steve duy I'm Brian kilme and I'm Angley
aart and click here to subscribe to the
Fox News YouTube page to catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis